If you were on the run from demon hunters,
what would you do?
The only home you ever knew is gone,
and now you're in a demon world
where everyone will hunt you down for food.
I'm going to break down the mistakes made,
what you should do and how to beat the demon world
in the Promised Neverland season two.
These kids have no idea,
but they're all about to die if they can't face
the horrors in this demon world because
their freedom has never looked so horrifying.
All of these kids are orphans, survivors
from the human cattle farm known as Grace Field,
and they try to survive everything
that this deadly forest offers them
just as they stop to catch their breath.
Just then, one of them fiddles with a pen.
The very same pen that fellow orphan Norman,
whose dead left behind for them.
Whether they activate a holographic image
deciphering the Morse code, the gang breaks
it and finds a message offering to help the kids
if they need it from the same mysterious man
from season one, William Minerva.
The gang further breaks down the codex and figures
out the coordinates of a mysterious place
in the distance that they should head to,
and with the gang having nothing else to rely on.
They trusted this eerie message
and start making their way there, but suddenly
they see a giant monster coming for them.
The children run for their lives and try to outwit
this terrifying beast by splitting up.
But all of a sudden, the monster gets killed
by none other than these demon hunters
who can now sense that Ray's nearby and demands
that he come out or else.
Okay, now listen good.
These demons standing on two legs
are similar to humans in terms
of being similar size and build,
but that's where the similarities end.
What they do have that we don't is
superhuman speed and reflexes.
Now that's all we know for now.
But let's be honest,
there's no way that we could take this demon out.
Not yet.
And knowing that there are variations
of demons out there means that it's a safe bet
that some of the very least can catch our scent
if we let them.
In this instance, it's fight or flight,
and I would definitely choose flight.
But our odds of running away are pretty slim
since Mr.
Demon has his pack of wild dogs with him.
So our best bet in this instance would be to use
the varying flora around us to better mask
are sent by quickly rubbing dirt leaves,
pine needles and anything else that we can find to
mask are sent.
This way, we'll be better able
to stay hidden, at least temporarily
while these demons are within our vicinity.
I mean, come on, we're only kids,
and at this very moment, you know, there's
no way in hell that we can take them on trapped
and with nowhere to go.
Ray comes out and claims
that everyone else is already dead.
But these demons don't believe a word
that this brat is spouting and chase him down
the rest of the gang.
And the distance wanders where Ray just went and
they suddenly hear the distinct noise of a whistle
right as they begin to figure out
that what they're hoping for
isn't true, that the demon hunters are near
and are going to get their flesh.
But fortunately for them,
their bad luck is cut short.
Just as Emma passes out,
someone suddenly calls out from behind them
and offers to lead them to safety.
This strange girl.
Elsewhere, Ray continues to run frantically
as he is hunted down by the demon dogs,
eventually cornering an exhausted ray
and they prepare to drag him back to hell itself
where it all started.
The human cattle farm where he came from.
But all of a sudden, his limp body is snatched
by a mysterious figure on horseback,
and he throws some scent blocker grenades.
Losing the demons for good.
But this isn't over,
and the demons won't stop until they find them.
Later, Ray wakes up to find himself in a strange
bunker and finds Emma resting there, too.
None of them know what the hell is going on.
Looks like they were helped by someone
and that certain someone was strange girl
who pops up from behind them and calms them down
by telling them that they're safe.
But this strange girl keeps the two kids on edge,
just as another strange
man appears from behind them.
Ray knows what Emma begins to fear that
their helpers are, in fact, demons themselves.
Emma and Ray demand to know where the other kids
are, and the demons tell them which way to go.
They rush off, only to find the kids
comfortably gathered around a campfire.
The demons then introduce themselves
as Mujika and Sonju, and that their heretic demons
that don't eat humans
all the while as they feared the entire gang food.
But something is up,
and Ray and Emma later go confront Sandra about
what the hell is really going on.
And he tells them that because of their faith
as social heretics, they don't eat humans.
He then tells them the world they live in is
not really how it appears and tells them of a war
thousand years ago
that happened between demons and humans,
and that a truce was formed, with both sides
agreeing that neither side would hurt the other
if they stayed within their half of the world
segregated and separated from one another,
and that some of humanity that was left behind on
the demand side would be used to create
human farms meant to feed a population of demons.
OK, Emma needs to seriously reconsider
her way of thinking
and potential rescue operation of the children
within Grace Field House,
because initially we didn't have any idea
as to the realities of our situation.
But we now know for a fact that Grace Field House
isn't the only human farm out there
and that the rest of the world,
or at least half of it, is run by demons.
This makes the chances of us
managing to help our brothers and sisters as.
From there, almost zero, and it's unlikely
that we ourselves will be able to change
the status quo since literally
half of the entire world operates this way.
If I'm a little girl called Emma, then I would
screw saving anyone else and I would live out
the rest of my days hiding out within a safe
bunker or hidden location with whatever
orphaned buddies I got left because realistically
there would it be too much that we could do?
And just like any old border, I doubt
the human world would be easy to cross into
if this has been the way of the world
for the past 1000 years.
The one thing that Emma lacks is the ability
to disregard the feelings of others
for the greater good, and this is one such trait
that will cost her dearly soon.
Emma and Norman then jump up and down
after hearing what they think is good news,
but the demon says that they'll never be able to
cross into the human territories and mentions that
in the thousand years since the truce was made,
no one has crossed between the two worlds.
But Emma and Ray are too naive to realize
that they'll likely never get there
and have no idea of what
hell awaits them on their journey.
The next day, Sonju and Mujika lead the kids
through the maze like tunnels as they guide them
towards the way out.
Emma and Ray then update the kids
on what Sonju said and offer their mission to meet
this mysterious William Minerva
first before figuring out
how to cross into the human territories.
Only then will they be able to save the rest of
their orphaned buddies from the Grace Field House.
Sandra and Mujika over the coming days
leading out of the maze, teach the kids
how to survive on their own in the wilderness
and even teach Emma how to hunt the day,
then finally arrives as the kids venture
out of the forest and into this desert canyon.
And Mujika and Sandra bid the kids farewell right
before Mujika gives Emma a charm for good luck.
But this group of orphans
don't realize that Sonju has other reasons
for letting them escape, and it's
way more sinister than anyone could ever imagine.
Later on, the orphans reach the coordinates
and find out that the secret location is not
what they think.
It's an underground bunker, and they discover
the eerie entrance into its lair,
and they begin to search the empty halls
and corridors of this strange cold place.
But they're in luck because they discovered
this place has everything they could ever need
food security, soil for farming, water,
and they even discover a letter
which welcomes them on getting to this bunker
by none other than William Minerva.
This is insane.
These kids have literally hit the jackpot
and have found the ultimate bunker,
but it can't be trusted just yet, and they should
take the proper precautionary measures
to make sure that this bunker
truly has all the basics.
They need to make sure that this place
is truly self-sustainable,
and they should also make a note
to dispose of their sense
from the ground trout leading up to the bunker
entrance, as any scent has the potential
to last for about two to three days on the ground
and could get picked up by demon hunters.
If we fail to cover our shit up and this problem
can be taken care of with a homebrew mixture
containing some 3% peroxide, distilled
water, baking soda and some unscented soap,
if the last one is available now,
when it comes to the actual bunker,
these kids will need to check
if there's proper air ventilation installed
that will be able to last for weeks,
if not months.
They need to check a steady
supply of water or water filtration.
They should also check for perishable goods.
For starters, first aid warm clothes
on the likely chance that their bunker
does not contain
some kind of crazy insulation between the walls.
And did I mention they'll also need tools
for general maintenance and base repairs
and batteries?
Because even if we do have it, I wouldn't
count on us having a steady supply of electricity,
and all of these kids need to start thinking about
this before they let their guard down and relax.
Ray then discovers a radio
which they use to listen in on the status of Grace
Field House, knowing the exact time
that their mom used to radio in.
But they hear nothing of note,
and they decide to check the radio
daily for any updates on
what is going on at their old orphanage.
Later, Emma and the gang find a locked door with a
keyhole and managed to open it with their pen,
and they find a scary, dark crimson red door
before they get to a room with a phone booth
and even a horrifying dead
end to room with scribbles of the word help
etched into the wall, along with a list of names
carved right by it.
Just then, the phone lets out a bellowing roar
and the gang holds their breath.
Someone is calling them
and within musters up some courage and answers it.
Hearing the voice of none
other than William Minerva,
he lets the gang in on his real name
being James Ratri, and informs the gang
that he used to be a part of the farm management
team that ran the human cattle farms.
But after seeing so many kids die,
he betrayed the demons and began to leaving clues
throughout the farms, leaving anybody who could
decipher his clues to this underground bunker.
Minerva
also tells the kids that they can choose to spend
the rest of their lives in that bunker,
or they could try and get to the human world.
And he gives Emma coordinates on how to get there
should they decide to leave this comfy place
and face the horrors of the unknown
that await them and the demons outside.
These little orphans then decide that
they will make a life within this bunker first
before going to rescue the rest of their brothers
and sisters from Grace Field House.
And then they will all venture to the human world
together as one big.
Big, happy family.
Or so they think months passed as the orphans
make this bunker their home,
but nothing is built to last forever,
and that's when their happiness finally runs out.
Suddenly, a massive explosion
erupts at the front entrance of the bunker,
alerting everyone that shit's about to go down
and incomes and swinging special.
Kid abducting forces could
descend down into the bunker and search every nook
and cranny that this bunker has.
Looking for the fleeing orphans?
But these little kids are crafty
son of a guns and managed to hide in a secret room
while they await this hell to blow over.
But they're missing two people just then done,
and this kid here get found by the soldiers,
forcing him to out with them
and retreat to the hidden room where the gang is
before they flee through a secret second exit.
Located right below the bunker, forcing all of
these tiny little children to run for their lives.
Okay, this group should have been prepared
for this, at least a little.
This is an apocalyptic world,
and our only home is one bunker
left behind by a man who we have no idea
if he's even alive or not.
They should not have expected this bunker
to last forever, and they should have prepared
emergency drills
practicing to all meet at a certain spot
within the bunker in the event of an emergency.
This way, Don and that kid with the white hair
could have known and reacted faster, right
as the explosion went off.
They also should have made it mandatory to carry
weaponry on them at all times, such
as forks and utensils, of which Don here
could have used to better handle that soldier.
This is a case example of failing to prepare
and preparing to fail because as the oldest kids,
Emma, Ray and Don should have known better
and prepared for the worst in advance.
Just then, a soldier spots
one of the kids aiming his gun right at them.
But these two kids are too fast for this guy,
causing him to fall off the cliff.
But the fleeing orphans troubles aren't over
because these soldiers end
up capturing a bunch of them,
causing Ray and Emma to give up.
But suddenly, out of nowhere,
this horrifying demon
monster busts through the trees, ripping up
every single living thing still standing,
allowing the kids to flee
and run like hell, as this monster
then starts to chase them down and elsewhere,
their luck continues to get a whole lot worse
because back at some unknown prison sits
the woman who raised all of these orphans to die
mother herself and the demons make a deal.
She'll get her freedom
and the kill switch removed from inside her chest
if she manages to catch every single orphan
who once called her mother,
and she accepts vowing to hunt all of them down,
no matter the cost.
The next day,
the kids make their way to a demon town
and put on some disguises
and sneak into the marketplace.
The kids glare and peek around at all
the various flesh
eating monsters who crave human flesh,
but the kids notice something.
These demons are in fact,
not that different from humans
as they go about their regular day
and even see some demon kids run past them,
showing these orphans that the world
is a little more complicated than they realize.
The gang eventually makes it back to their hideout
a demon heretic church
where the rest of the
fleeing orphans are hiding out and they hand out
to what little food that they found.
Emma is dying inside of the situation,
wanting to give her family a better life,
but the kids laugh off their sad situation,
and Emma and Ray discuss their uncertain future
with little food
and no hope they can't go back to save
the rest of the orphans from Grace Field House.
Not without a proper shelter.
The next day,
the group heads back to the demon marketplace
to pick up some spices for their captured fish.
But due to the wind currents,
their scent gets discovered by these demons,
who then begin to suspect
that there are humans nearby
until suddenly a final gust of wind
gives off their human scent for good.
The kids then run like mad as these two demons
chased them down to enjoy a special meal.
Okay, while these adorable little snots
are adorable, they're even dumber than they look.
The wind dictates greatly
the amount that a scent is dispersed into the air.
And just like hunters, this group of kids
should have accounted for wind factor at least
slightly, as their disguises only fell apart
when the demons caught the kid's scent.
They already caught fish.
The fact that they felt the need
to go to the nearby market for spice
while they are wanted fugitives is beyond me.
When you're a wanted fugitive,
you do not make unnecessary trips.
Yet in the instance of the gang
getting discovered,
the group messed up on the one advantage that they
ended up gaining as a result of their running.
And that was the fact
that they led the demons down that deserted alley.
No one's around.
They had the weaponry
and the skills necessary to kill them
if they had just pulled themselves together.
And not to mention they have lived on the demon
side of the world for some time now.
So it's not like
they've never seen a demon before.
The fleeing orphans run terrified, flying past
all the street walk stalls and cellars,
and they split up. But Ryan and I get cornered.
They are trapped.
Suddenly, a demon jumps down from the rooftop
and even more demons cornered them.
But the two initial demons
still try to fight for their delicious food.
But then all of a sudden, this demon
lets out his sweet etzinger style assassin
blade and cuts them down for good.
Revealing to be none other
than the very same orphan they thought to be dead,
Norman, he's alive.
So cue the waterworks and a good old buddy
slap to the face because.
The gang rejoices once more,
but they have no idea the consequences
of reuniting with Norman later on.
Emma and Ray fill Norman in on how they escaped,
and Norman reveals where he's been all this time
and the truth couldn't be more horrifying.
Back in season one,
he wasn't sent to die, but to be used as a lab rat
for intelligence experiments at a research
facility called Lomita, where they used Norman
and other intelligent humans to figure out
how to raise human livestock more effectively.
The horrors of what LAMDA has plant
will make those human farms seem like nothing.
Norman also reveals the most horrifying,
insane thing ever and the reason as to
why demons need to feed on humans.
Because if they don't, their bodies
and minds will regress, turning them back
into terrifying creatures
without any self-control.
This is why they can't stop feeding on humans.
The gang is then shocked to the core,
but Norman says that using data that he stole from
Lamb does lab gives weaponized
a drug that can be used to regress demons
intentionally and that he has enough of the stuff
to destroy the whole nearby town.
But Emma has a huge problem with this,
and she thinks that all demons
are just like humans
with their own lives and families,
and she can't help
but think that this is a terrible plan.
The next morning, Emma and Ray are introduced
to a few of Norman's escapee friends
that he also helped escape from lambdas facility,
and they come to realize
that everyone here hates the demons
and can't wait to kill every last one of them.
But Emma finally gathers up
the courage and tells Norman how she really feels,
telling him
that the demons are forced to eat brains to live.
And that means that they're not that different
from humans who simply want to survive,
and that the humans have to be better than
the demons if they are to co-exist in this world .
OK, well,
I do appreciate Emma's ability to have empathy.
She's not thinking with her head,
but with her heart.
But in reality,
the way the status quo has been for a long time
over 1000 years will likely remain unchanged
due to the Demon Society's reliance on human
farming from the non egalitarian ways to the poor
people's dependance on meat to survive,
and not to mention the whole noble classes who
will surely put up a fight when shit hits the fan.
There's just no way that Emma would be able
to stop the production of meat
or the public's reliance on meat consumption
without absolutely massive effort
and resources that she doesn't have.
Not to mention that no one has crossed
through to the human portal
in 1000 years, and we don't even know
if the human world would let us enter their site.
They very well could turn us away
and send us right back to where we came from.
This means that there are way
too many variables to plan for,
and it makes her plan in wanting to save everyone
so unrealistic.
It's nauseating.
Norman, at the very least, wants to incite chaos
by putting up a fight
to read this world of the demons.
And if we compare his insane plan based on brute
force to Emma's heartfelt, nonviolent one, well,
I believe it's safe to say it whose plan
would really be a more efficient solution.
Norman pays little attention to naive Emma's ways
as he reveals the regression
drug right then and there and all of its glory.
But the party's cut short, as Emma
then tells Norman something seemingly insane that
there are demons out there who don't eat humans
and that she's seen two of them herself.
Sonju and Mujika.
And that's when Norman freezes
up, thinking that there's no way
that the heretic girl could be still alive.
Norman freaks out.
Hearing only the rumors that began over
700 years ago about a demon that could survive
without eating humans and could turn other demons
into being just like her through drinking
only a drop of her blood.
But Norman so intent on making sure that this plan
succeeds, he thinks that Sonju and Mujika
pose a serious threat to his weaponized drug plan,
which means he has to kill them now.
This freaks out Goody two shoes, Emma,
but Norman lays it down logically for the girl,
saying that they likely won't
just sit by and idly watch as their own kind
is destroyed,
which means Sonju and Mujika need to die.
Emma then reveals her reverse Uno card and shows
that she has the coordinates to the human shelter,
meaning that they can just run away to
the human world rather than kill all the demons.
But Norman shuts her down again
and says that her map has been compromised
and that the man himself, William Minerva
and all of his supporters have been killed.
Emma's pure spirited heart drops for a sack
as she tries to find her words, but Norman then
reveals that there is, in fact, one more portal
that will take them to the human world.
Located deep below Grace Field House itself,
the very same orphanage that they all grew up in.
But Norman says that there's no hope of them
reaching the portal alive
and that killing all of the demons
is the only shot at surviving within this world.
However, thanks to Emma's
drama queen Nature and Beady Eyes.
Norman agrees to try Emma's plan
first by finding and utilizing MUTACOES abilities
to help the demons natural and human meat anymore,
and that Emma has five days to find Sonju
and Mujika before he'll begin his plan
to test his weaponized drug on the nearby village.
Little does Emma know that Norman is full of shit.
OK. Emma is the most kind
hearted person that I know,
but I think she might be a little local
and a bit of a deadweight
because her plan is full of holes
and with no guarantees whatsoever.
We can't know for sure
that Moukoko will let us use her to help mankind,
as we never discussed this before,
and there's little to no certainty
that if we can't convince her
that she'll just sit back
and let us resort to Plan
B, which is to literally kill all of her own kind.
So really, Norman's plan is the only plan
that sounds like it will actually work,
and it is the same plan that has the least amount
of variables to account for.
And so with this being said, we need to be the
most cruel and most savage bastard that we can be.
And like Norman, take matters into our own hands.
If I was Norman, I'd resort
to going to extreme lengths to make sure that Emma
doesn't mess up our plan, since she's really
the only one who has any contention with it.
Norman should have known that
Emma would not go along with this
and that she will get in the middle of his plan
one way or another,
which means we need to shut her up permanently
or tie up if we don't want to kill her
and prevent her from meddling with our shit.
Until the first phase of our plan is over,
which involves the decimation of the village
because we can't take any chances with her
or Rae, for that matter the next day.
Norman waives Rae and Emma goodbye
as the two set out to find the two heretic demons.
But Norman has other plans and talks
with his teammates, who reveals that thanks to
lambdas experiments, they don't have much time
left on this Earth and will soon die, which means
that they don't have time to wait for Emma back
at the Children's Hideout at the Heretic Church.
Emma fills in the rest of the kids
with the situation,
and that she'll set out
to try and find Sonju and Mujika.
And over the coming days, the gang searches
high and low in this mysterious forest,
looking desperately for Sonju and Mujika
using what Sonju taught them to find clues
left by them within this forest.
But the wild is a terrifying place
because all of a sudden this monster busts through
looking for flesh, causing the gang to split up
and fire arrows right at this beast nearby.
Elsewhere, Sonju and Mujinga hear the nearby roars
just as Mujika notices
the amulet that she gave Emma hanging on a bush,
which means Emma must be nearby.
This beast is literally 100 times the size of us,
and all we have are these arrows and our brains.
Now this monster has the advantage,
but what I'm certain about is its weakness
by the dozens of eyes it's sporting.
I'm pretty sure if we had one of those,
it would hurt a lot.
But trying to get a clean shot from far away
will likely be hard as hell.
So we need to close the gap
between this demon and our arrows,
and this is where the varying trees around us
could prove to be advantageous.
If I was Emma and Ray, I'd work together
to make this demon chase after us and hide
within some of the exposed tree roots that
some of these ginormous trees are likely to have.
Now, unlike us, increasing weakness with age
is not a universal law of nature,
and this can apply with certain trees because
as they increase with age, they can get stronger.
And judging
by the size of these trees in the background, I'm
pretty certain they can take a pretty good punch.
So what Emma and Ray could do
is make a run for it, identify certain exposed
tree roots and hide within them.
Then once this beast gets close enough
trying to eat us,
we could use our bows and arrows
to puncture its eyes.
This step could be repeated dozens of times
until the creature becomes completely blind
or runs away from being unable to reach us.
Being too difficult of a prey to eat,
this is the best way that these kids could bridge
the gap between their arrows
and this monster's weak point its eyes.
Just then, as Emma runs for her sweet life
and about to get devoured, whole
Ray comes in sliding like Hawkeye and shoots
an arrow right into this beast eye hole,
just as Sandra appears and slices its head
clean off, saving the day.
Mujika then comes to Emma's aid
as she tells them that she needs their help.
But the sweet moment is cut short
by a large eruption in the distance
right with the Demon Village is,
and it's at that moment that Emma and Rae realize
that Norman lied to them, and the chaos ensues
as demons left and right throughout
the village are plagued by the effects of the drug
losing their sanity, composure and mind.
And they can do nothing but watch as their bodies
regress into horrifying monsters,
men, women and children.
Demons all mindlessly turn on each other,
feeding on everyone.
It is at this moment that Norman and his comrades
descend from the hills just as Norman prepares
to kill this little girl
right before he stopped by this old demon,
the same old demon who was at the Heretic Church
where the orphans took refuge in earlier.
Norman then readies his blade,
but chokes at the last moment,
hearing the old demon
call out to his granddaughter, calling her
the same name as that of his best friend
Emma, causing Norman to freeze in fear and regret.
He can't kill the innocent.
Norman's free spell is then broken
for a quick second right as he tries but
fails to kill the old demon, forcing the old demon
to make the little girl drink his blood,
causing all of her regression to stop,
meaning that this old demon is just like Mujika.
Just then, Emma shows up to the village
and convinces Norman, making him
realize the despicable acts that he's cost,
forcing him to come to a census.
Showing up late to the party is Sonju and Mujika,
who begin donating their blood
to help cure the regression turned
and demons trying to end the horrors that Norman
and his team started and with no time to waste.
Sonju tells Emma and the gang to quickly retreat
before people find out who did this,
and everybody heads back to their demon
heretic hideout.
But as they return, they find out from the radio
the worst news of all that their orphaned buddies
back at Grace Field House are about
to get shipped out, meaning they're about to get.
Chopped up for meat.
Little do they realize that this is all a part
of their old nemesis, mother's plans
to lure the kids back to Grace Field House.
The Orphan Gang
then sits back and plans their attack
just as the old man even appears
and says that he too is a heretic demon
with special blood and that he found a device
on the body of a facility worker
who collapsed just outside of the facility
that Norman escaped from and gives it to Emma.
He then rants about how
he could have given his blood to the demons
and saved them all these years,
but was afraid of being exposed
, basically siding with Emma and her team
and making everything hunky dory again.
What's up anyway?
Weaves Domino, but here we've got to chime in.
You know, we can't let Griff have all the fun.
So, Albert, tell me,
what do you think about season two?
What are your thoughts?
I understand the criticism of season two
because season one has so much great
horror moments in it,
but season two feels more like an action movie.
Well, this at this point,
the kids know what they're doing.
You know the jig is up.
We know about the demons and all that,
so it's about them fighting back.
So like, the mystery was kind of taken away.
You know what I mean?
And also, we don't know their overall story
because their goals keep shifting every episode.
Of course, they want to go to the bunker
and then they want it to go to the human side,
and then they wanted to free the demons.
I think they should have had a better
overarching goal that we could follow.
That's true. That's true.
But yeah, you know, it was
it was a good watch overall, though, but
oh god, I'll bet the demons have found my hideout.
But real quick 80% of you guys watch you and not
subscribe to be my best friend and subscribe.
But now back to the video
and then turns on the device
that the old demon gave her
and finds out that these are the blueprints
to grace field house and its underground base,
and everything that they need
to get to the human world, turning the tide
on their war with the evil demons as the gang,
including Norman , prepared to save their orphaned
classmates and escape to the human world.
However, the night before their big rescue plan,
this glasses guy
picks up the radio and begins
conspiring with lambda head Peter Ratri,
and he makes a sinister deal
all the orphan kids in exchange for his freedom.
The next day, the gang sets the plan in motion,
writing hot air balloons filled with regression
drugs to take the demon security out
as the others plan to infiltrate the plants
from the hot air balloons and get the kids out
before guiding everybody to the human portal.
Just as these adorable little snapshots are laid
blissfully unaware to the human slaughterhouse,
the hot air balloons finally reach the perimeter
as demons begin to take them out one by one.
But to their surprise, the balloons are empty
because it turns out the glasses guy set them up.
Suddenly, a huge explosion erupts from the hot air
balloons as dozens of demons die and Sonju drops
in like a stud and kills
the remaining demons elsewhere, and the kids
reach the tunnel location and head underground,
slipping in through the back of the plant
and taking out this demon as glasses
guy hacks the security cameras, blinding
Peter Ratri and his demon army.
The smallest of the kids
dress up in the same uniform
as the orphan kids getting shipped out and slip
in while the mothers leave the room,
helping all the little orphans escape before
locking the mothers inside the entrance walls.
Everybody finally reaches
the majestic Portal Hall entrance way, right
as they get surrounded by an army of mothers.
Looks like Peter Ratri
and Mother were onto them from the start,
but nothing is, as it seems, as the mother
pulls a double whammy backstabbing Peter Ratri
revealing to him
that all the mothers kill switches inside
their bodies were neutralized
when Glass's guy hacked the entire system earlier.
If Peter Ratri went through the trouble
of implanting all the mothers to ensure they don't
double cross him,
then maybe he should have thought
about implementing a second failsafe
switch on the off chance.
The main one didn't work because relying on one
method alone can hold all of these mothers hostage
is the dumbest thing that he could have done,
and it's not very super villainy of him.
In fact, this was about as evil as those bad guys
in films who always spend about ten minutes
telling the good guy
their entire evil plan, only to have them escape.
Eventually, if Peter Ratri wanted to ensure
that no one would ever betray him,
then he should have been diabolical
with his insurance strategy.
Hear me out now.
If I was an evil super villain
running from a human meat
farming business, I would have had the mothers
impregnated from the start of their career
through IVF fertility treatments.
And then after I would have taken
their newborn babies from them to be raised
in a separate non-meat farm facility for life.
This way on the off chance that one
or all of the mothers managed to escape
or disarm their implanted kill switches,
then we simply could have used their very own
children as hostages.
I know, I know, 2020 hindsight.
So sad, but this would have been a cool
alternative and also sounds super diabolical.
I like it.
Peter Rabbit
released cornered with his back against the wall,
but has one less trick up his sleeve
because he reveals that a backup of Demon Army
is coming to kill everyone in this room.
But in an absolutely insane twist of events,
it turns out that these demons
are not here to kill the kids, but Peter Ratri
and the demons running the meat farm.
And we find out that Sonju and the old demon
used their blood to cure all the demons
from the nearby town,
freeing them from their dependance on human meat,
meaning they don't have to feed on humans anymore
to survive.
But Peter Raftery doesn't give two shits about
any of this sweet news and condemns Emma and Rae
claiming that humans will simply destroy and mess
everything up that they've worked so hard for.
Right?
As he exits stage left by slitting his own throat,
Emma then forgives mother
for everything that she did and invites them
and all the others to join them in the human world
and all of which she gracefully accepts.
But right before they enter the.
Emma Ray Norman and his teammates
and some of the demons tell the little kids
and mother that they'll stay behind
to rescue all the kids within the demon world
and that eventually they'll meet again
as the grand entrance portal door closes
behind on Emma as her and her crew set out
to save the rest of the kids
within the demon world
and go to change the course of history
for the first time in 1000 years.
And if you don't want to get canceled
after season two to forget Eliza Skype, comment
and check out the horrible playlist on below.